foreign
[Music]
are being made every single day
and with vertex AI you can start
leveraging this new tech in your
applications right now if you haven't
seen our last video about image
generation and editing be sure to check
out the link below in this video we'll
be taking a look at some of the new
features including image captioning and
visual q a
let's go
you may already be familiar with the
image generation feature on vertex AI
where you can type in a text prompt and
get an image generated based on that
text but did you know that you can now
upload an image as input and have the AI
generate a text caption describing that
image
this is our new image captioning feature
in vertex AI
let's see in action
in the vision section of generative AI
Studio you can click on the new caption
button and upload your own image
then click generate caption and our AI
will generate a human readable caption
describing what's happening in that
image
this feature is also accessible via an
API so you can embed this functionality
directly into your applications
some cool use cases we've already seen
with this feature have been in
automatically generating product
descriptions for e-commerce businesses
and making images more accessible to
visually impaired users we are really
excited to see what new Solutions this
technology will power in the future so
share your ideas in the comments below
okay
let's talk about the next new feature in
vertex AI
you can now ask questions about images
I know that sounds a bit like magic so
let's just see it in action
same as before we navigate to The Vision
section of generative AI Studio
then we click on the new visual q a
button
we upload our own image
and then finally we type in the question
we want answered about that image
for example you could ask what is the
neck type of this shirt
the AI will then generate an answer to
your question based on the visual
contents of the image
now this feature enables some really
unique possibilities for Developers
for example building interactive
shopping experiences
like you could be clothes shopping
online and want to ask questions like
what is the style of that jacket called
or another use case might be in building
richer accessibility for a media app
so that you might be watching a film and
want to ask a question like what is the
person on the left hand side of the
screen holding in their hands if you
have some cool use case in mind
definitely share them in the comments
below
and again same as before and with the
rest of the features this functionality
can be embedded directly into your apps
via an API and run at scale those are
some of the new image generation
features in vertex AI
let us know in the comments what you're
planning to build with them and check
out the links below to learn more about
getting started
[Music]
foreign